لقد قلت في وقت سابق اليوم أنه إذا
لم يتم إحياء برنامج jcpoa في الأسابيع الثلاثة أو الأربعة المقبلة ،
فلن تتمكن بعد ذلك من
إعطاء العالم تفاصيل دقيقة عن تقدم إيران ،
لذا فقط اشرح أين
تعتقد أننا موجودون لديك اقترحت ثلاثة
أو أربعة  أسابيع كل ما تبقى قبل
أن يتم توجيه ضربة قاضية لهذا الاتفاق
ما يجري في ما
تخطط له إيران في هذه المرحلة
السبب في ذلك بسيط جدًا أه لدينا
عدد من الوسائل للتحقق
من
أنشطة إيران في عدد من  المجالات
المتعلقة
بكاميرات jcpoa كما ذكرت ، لدينا
أنظمة أخرى عبر الإنترنت تمنحنا
تدفقات تعطينا
مراقبة الكميات التي يتم
تخصيب اليورانيوم ، على سبيل المثال التي تم
تخصيبها وما إلى ذلك وما إلى ذلك ، لذلك
عندما تبدأ إيران في الحد من هذه
الوصول
في مرحلة ما إذا  كان من المقرر
إحياء
برنامج jcpoa حتى
يحدث ذلك ، يحتاج المشاركون إلى أن يكون لديهم
خط أساس للمبالغ الضرورية لمعرفة
ما تمتلكه إيران أو
لا تملكه حتى يتسنى لنا التحقق من وقتك
ليس لديك أنه من
المستحيل تقنيًا الحصول على اتفاق أو
يمكنك الحصول على اتفاق على أساس عدم وجود
معلومات أفترض أنها لن تصل
إلى
هذا ، ولهذا السبب نقول أن
هذا أمر خطير للغاية وله
عواقب بالطبع
تقديري ليس تقديريًا سياسيًا ،
إنه تقني
يعتمد تقديري على الوقت النسبي
الذي يمكننا
تحمله لعدم
الوصول إلى هذا النوع من المعلومات ،
وبعبارة أخرى
مقدار الوقت الذي يمكننا الحصول عليه مع
أجهزة الطرد المركزي التي تدور مع
يستمر إنتاج الماء الثقيل
مع بناء وتجميع
أجهزة الطرد المركزي دون أن يكون لدينا
رأي في ذلك لأن وجهة نظرك
ستكون ما حدث
إذا سُمح لهم بالقيام بذلك
دون
التحقق ، دعنا نوضح أنه يمكننا
إعادة البناء أكثر أو أقل يمكننا أن نتمكن من
إعادة بناء ما قد حدث بشكل أو بآخر
ولكن هذه
التوقعات هي شيء تفعله
لفترة زمنية قصيرة نسبيًا
لا يمكنك الاستمرار فيها لأشهر وأشهر
دون أي وصول بدون أي
معلومات ، ثم قل جيدًا أنك تعرف أن
هناك هذا المبلغ على الأرجح ، ولهذا
السبب نقول إن ثلاثة أسابيع هي
شيء يمكننا التعامل معه ،
لذا فهو ليس سياسيًا.
iaea
لك